this was just a routine tasks we had a
IMAX camera on the back of Muriel's car
which is a black car it was just above
the roll bar and we expected to do a
simple task with Mario filming his son
Michael in the red car in front so we
got the camera ready the and readys
arrived and they wanted to get going but
it started to rain and we hadn't
considered the possibility of doing this
in the rain because it could very easily
destroy the camera but we decided to bag
the camera anyway just to be ready if
the rain ceased we would we would do the
shot Mary was anxious to get going
wanted to do something so we put them in
the cars and I told Mario and Michael
look just take it real easy because you
can't see that extra 20 miles an hour on
film so you know just keep it below 200
miles an hour so the rain continued to
fall and it got pretty heavy and we sent
the cars out of anyway thinking the
camera was protected well the cars went
by the first time around and they were
doing about 230 miles an hour on the
straight the plastic had ripped off the
camera and the new mahasti manager
leaned over to me and said well they're
racing now you can't stop him they just
got into a race between the two of them
in the rain with the sine X camera on
the back of Muriel's car and I remember
thinking I hope Meredith remembers to
turn the camera on we weren't even sure
if the camera would run because it was
completely sold but the camera ran and
it was a great shot
you